basta
ora la rigido nella scatola e non
riaprire o mai più
ok berlino tu non cercare di prenderla
mi raccomando
[Musica]
poche e ben chiusa almeno credo
anzi l'ha chiuso nell'armadio così
berlino non ci arriva ok
[Musica]
vediamo
perché mi guardi così prodotto
[Musica]
sì
sentito grillo
[Musica]
a me li sentiamo qualcuno
sì non so cosa succede non so sembra
stranissimo fa e sembra che la bambola
si muova sì lo so che è assurdo è solo
una bambola di plastica ma ti giuro che
mi è sembrato di vederlo a muoversi
praticamente in sto qua in camera e
abbiamo chiuso la porta nello studio
sono che poi ho trovato la porta aperta
e la bambola era per terra nel corridoio
no marino era qui con me perché non mi
credi parla anche silos o un falco di
carboni parla roma parla in modo strano
diverse come se fosse arrabbiato cattiva
[Musica]
no
ehi guarda lì sono qua su ti piace
sempre d'esame ho in mente un piano
geniale e di somma sentire le mie
istruzioni e ti darò tanti cappellini il
mio piano è quello di eliminare la tua
padroncina vedi solo di stanarla e al
resto ci pensano rio la farò barile per
6 3
chissà perché mi guardi così lo sapevo
il migliore amico dell'uomo
sempre fedele al vostro salone si sa e
ne vorrà dire che sarà peggio e allora
[Musica]
aspetta un momento sentito un rumore ti
richiamo più tardi
sì ciao
[Musica]
berlino
che cosa è successo qua
[Musica]
la scatola sei stato tu
marino la ripresa tutto qua come hai
fatto
[Musica]
non mi faccio a prenderla da qua
tufello bambola berlino dimmi dove l'hai
messa sotto il letto dove lei messo a
berlino non sto scherzando
tu sei merino
berlino aiutami
[Musica]
non capisco
e sembrato come se mi stesse attaccando
berlino è visto anche tu non capisco se
si muove veramente o è frutto della mia
immaginazione
sicuramente nessuno mi crederà
penseranno che solo un pazzo mi è venuta
un'idea le attaccherò una videocamera
addosso
così se si muove realmente potrò
dimostrarlo a tutti tramite il video è
un'idea geniale
ora devo solo trovare dove ho messo quel
mini videocamera c eccola è la camera
eccola per fortuna l'ho trovato
ok questa dovrebbe andare benissimo che
dovrei metterla come cavolo si metteva
[Musica]
ecco fatto
guardate sono l'eterna a questa
maledettissima bambola
[Musica]
ecco perché ho fatto
ora devo azionarla
[Musica]
fatti o maledetta bambola prendiamo un
berlino
andiamo via da qua e vino
[Musica]
guarda guarda
berlino
barberino
[Musica]